-Finally, you guys, tomorrow
is the last day of January,
so I thought it would be nice to
give a little recap
of the entire month.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ukulele plays ]
♪ It's the end of January ♪
♪ What a big month
for Prince Harry ♪
♪ He wrote a wrote a book,
and did you see this ♪
♪ He got frostbite... ♪
-On his penis.
-♪ Congress voted
for a speaker ♪
♪ It turned out
to be a squeaker ♪
♪ McCarthy said,
"I got this, bro." ♪
♪ Then he lost... ♪
-14 times in a row.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Poor George Santos
under fire ♪
♪ Everyone says
that he's a liar ♪
♪ His résumé
is not so clean ♪
♪ Plus, he used to be... ♪
-A drag queen?!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
♪ Biden, Trump,
and Pence got caught ♪
♪ with houses
full of secret docs ♪
♪ How the heck
could you forget? ♪
♪ Joe kept them next to... ♪
-My Corvette.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ The robot movie "M3GAN"
crushed ♪
♪ And people loved
"The Last of Us" ♪
♪ "Avatar," it didn't bomb ♪
♪ It made us all say... ♪
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Eagles/Chiefs,
Super Bowl ♪
♪ Niners/Bengals watched
from home ♪
♪ Can't talk trash from
your couch, gotta... ♪
-Know your role
and shut your mouth.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
-♪ It was the first month
of the year ♪
♪ We all got through it
without beer ♪
♪ But February isn't dry ♪
♪ So let's get trashed
on Valentine's ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪